talking about it all morning long very  excited to see what's about to happen  right next to me here Nutcracker with a  Latin twist back this holiday season  with Jordans studio and we've got some  of the dancers joining us live this  morning with a little dose of what you  can expect so let's hear it let's see  The Nutcracker with the loud and twist  take it away guys  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  all right I guess that's the end of the  music  thanks guys oh my goodness wow  that of course is the Parada from The  Nutcracker with sugar plum and the  prince and we have Clara there thank you  all so much just wonderful wonders  thanks guys now the Latin twist will  come out uh in in different aspects of  the performance which you can catch two  nights only this Saturday and Sunday 6  p.m all the information there is on your  screen tickets are 35  um at the West Las Vegas Library and  don't forget some of the proceeds go to  help CCSD polices K-9 units